welcome to the open source AI game
channel where you have 48 hours to make
a game using AI tools to push the
boundaries of game development over a
thousand of you have signed off making
this the largest ever AI focused game
Champs
right now but first rules you can work
alone or in a team of any size your game
needs to be in English run on web or
Windows and use at least one open source
AI tool which could be as simple as
generate an asset with stable diffusion
but we encourage you to be creative with
your use of AI ratings after submitting
you have a way to rate each other's
games based on three criteria fun
creativity and theme so what's the
almost there after the games are rated
our three judges will play the top 10
games showcase them then choose the
winner any questions join our Discord
and finally the theme is expanding go